For working with time series data,
pandas provide a number of functions
to compute moving statistics.
We use rolling mean function to
compute the rolling mean of the SPY.
Note that rolling mean is
not a DataFrame method but
it is a function with
the pandas library.
So we wouldn't be able
to call def.rollingmean.
Instead we pass in a set of values for
which rolling mean has to be
calculated as the first parameter.
Now let's go for this.
Firstly, let's get SPY data in
our data frame for the year 2012.
We also go ahead and plot the SPY data.
Notice that we retain
the matplotlib axis object so
that we can add to it later on.
Next we call the rolling mean
function from pandas library, and
pass in two parameters.
As explained before the first
parameter would be the values for
which the rolling mean
has to be calculated.
Hence we pass our data frame
containing SPY values.
The next parameter is the window size,
for which the mean will be calculated.
We use a period of 20 days.
This will return a series
consisting of the rolling mean.
It is always good to
visualize the rolling mean.
So we plot the series
using the plot function.
This time, while plotting the rolling
mean, we pass in the matplotlib
axis object so
that it gets added to the existing plot.
Notice that we specified a label
is equal to rolling mean.
This will be used to
create a plot legend.
Let's add the legend and
some access labels to our plot.
So here we add our legend to
the upper left corner of the plot
at the X label and the Y label.
Finally we are all set to view the plot.
Observe that the rolling mean
has missing initial values.
The reason is that we defined
a window period of 20 days, so
the first 20 days there are no values.
Also notice how it follows
the movement of the draw prices, and
is also less spiky.